what do they have against people who are
different anyway Esmeralda you are one
of the most underrated Disney characters
ever The Hunchback of Notre DOM is often
overlooked by Disney fans because it's
so serious but some fans are missing out
because you are one of the best Disney
women ever you're fighting for your
people's rights even though all the odds
are stacked against you and let's be
honest you have some of the best clap
backs in the entire Disney universe I
have chores to do it was nice seeing you
[Music]
Disney characters are known for being
memorable but some of the most legendary
moments are their witty clap backs there
are some Disney characters who are just
really good at delivering a quick burn
keep watching to find out which disney
lady is the fiercest of them all she
really means in 1995 Disney released a
new Disney princess movie but it was
different from all its predecessors
Pocahontas was the first princess of
color to get her own movie since Jasmine
was the secondary character in Aladdin
and Pocahontas was such a cool character
she is one of the most empowered
princesses ever she saves her people
from the colonists and totally rocks
John Smith's world but the poet and
princess is likable for a lot more
reasons than her epic songs and
storyline she has sarcasm and clap backs
down to an art Pocahontas is expected to
marry a powerful man in their tribe but
kocoum isn't exactly her type
he's stoic and kind of boring Pocahontas
his friend thinks kocoum is a total
hottie but our princess isn't feeling it
she doesn't hold back at all she says
especially loved to smile and delivers
it in a perfectly sarcastic tone kocoum
doesn't really smile he doesn't know how
to paint with all the colors of the wind
so Pocahontas just has no time for him
he's so serious Alice in Wonderland is a
wild animated film from Disney's classic
era it's based on the famous novel alice
is a curious little girl who falls down
the hole into a really bizarre world an
important part of the movie is when she
stumbles upon a tea party the party is
hosted by the Mad Hatter and he's well
mad he's more than a little nutty but
there's a lot more to him than meets the
eye the Mad Hatter is one of the wisest
characters in the movie forget the
caterpillar and the Cheshire Cat the Mad
Hatter likes to speak the truth but he
sounds nutty when he does one of the
best lines is the clap back to Alice
tells her
isn't that the truth we bet you can
think of a lot of people you'd like to
say that same thought back to too many
people just don't think before they
speak
but the Mad Hatter totally calls Alice
out on it this little bit of wisdom is
one that has totally stuck with us over
the years sometimes the best way to
insult someone is when they aren't aware
of what you're doing and Belle from
Beauty and the Beast is a master at
those subtle clap backs Korbel she is
really smart because she spends all her
free time reading the most popular guy
in town is interested in her but only
because she's beautiful he doesn't
appreciate her brain Gaston is basically
the worst type of guy he's shallow and
dumb and he thinks way too highly of
himself Belle keeps trying to turn him
down politely but Gaston just isn't
getting the message there are some
people that you have to let down gently
so they don't react badly look what
happens when Belle stands up to him
later in the movie he is so angry he
goes to attack the guy she loves but
early on she tells him you were
positively primeval it's not a
compliment she's saying he hasn't
evolved and is nothing more than a brute
but he doesn't know what the word mean
so he thinks it's a compliment he's no
monster Gaston you are we are so excited
for the new Mulan movie that comes out
in 2020 but that doesn't mean we don't
love the 1998 version the original Mulan
is one of Disney's funniest movies a lot
of the humor is thanks to moo shu
Mulan's dragon who is voiced by Eddie
Murphy Mushu is a great companion but he
is full of sass he does really help me
lawn out as she tries to become a
soldier but he gives her grief in the
meantime it's hard to pick which one of
Moo shus quips is the best because there
are just so many Malan is supposed to be
a soldier and she needs to look like an
intimidating man so no one finds out
she's a girl when she's getting ready in
the military camp moo shu is determined
not to dilute her he tells her we laugh
every time we see this scene Mulan is
only frightening enough to scare bunny
slippers of course moo shu eats his
words later when Mulan saves all of
China
and the baby is all grown up and and
save in China Disney has been giving us
strong female characters for decades and
the Aristocats is just one example the
1970 movie is about some high society
kittens who get kidnapped the feral
Tomcat helps them get home
Marie is definitely the star of the show
[Music]
she's a super sassy kitten she's fancy
and she calls herself a lady Maria's
proof that you can be girly while also
being tough she is often up to no good
with her brothers and she is never one
to shy away from putting them in their
place Marie's most memorable line is a
great mantra for girls everywhere she
says she said this to get out of trouble
of course there's a good chance she
really did start that fight memory holds
her head high and stands up for herself
she is one cool cat this is one of the
most memorable Disney quotes ever and
it's definitely the best clap back in
Aristocats princess leia organa join the
ranks of Disney Princesses a few years
ago now that Disney owns the Star Wars
franchise Luke and Leia are part of the
family Leia stole our hearts in Episode
four a new hope she might be a princess
but she's one of the toughest characters
ever she's a rebel fighter and she's got
a mouth on her of course that mouth gets
her into some trouble at times but she
definitely knows how to insult someone
the best scene in the first Star Wars
film is when she confronts a general
Tarkin even though she's been captured
it's clear that she has the upper hand
when it comes to intellect first she
compares Darth Vader to a dog who is
being held on a leash by Tarkin I should
be expected to find you holding Vader's
leash then she straight up tells the
general that he smells I recognized your
foul stench when I was brought on board
all he could say was the order to
terminate your life but does that get
layered down no way she says I had the
courage take the responsibility
ouch which disney lady is even sassier
than leia keep watching to find out
disney writers have been dishing out the
cloth bags long before we had the phrase
sick burn it's good to know that some
things never change at Disney like all
the sarcasm Sleeping Beauty came out in
1959 and it still has some of the most
savage quips of course there's
Maleficent
she's got no patience for silly fairies
who she thinks are fools but even those
good fairies candle out the sass is that
just part of being a fairy
when flora and Merryweather are making
Aurora's dress they have no patience
with each other Merryweather is wearing
the dress while flora makes adjustments
she tells Florida flora does n't get mad
she just collapsed back with an insult
of her own she's not wrong Aurora looks
lovely in the dress when it's finished
tensions had to run high in that small
cabin in the woods with three fairies
raising a princess we bet there are a
lot of snarky one-liners lilo and Stitch
is one of Disney's most heartwarming
films lilo is a lonely little girl who
is being raised by her sister after
their parents passed away she's always
getting into trouble and is in danger of
being taken from Nanny she adopts what
she thinks is a dog but it's actually an
alien they heal together and it's the
sweetest what's not sweet is Myrtle
she's the worst mean girl ever she's the
ringleader of the little girls and she
is awful - lilo lilo can clap back
pretty well but the best clip comes from
myrtles Lackey Yuki Myrtle tells Yuki
innocently chimes in and says Myrtle is
stunned and instantly gets upset of
course it's really sad that Myrtle
doesn't have a dad anymore but that's no
excuse for being a brat girls should
lift each other up not bring each other
down it's such a subtle zinger and Yuki
delivers it so perfectly
one of Disney's most overlooked and
underrated films is The Hunchback of
Notre Dame and we have to admit it
doesn't really fit the mold of a typical
Disney movie it is really dark Quasimodo
is mistreated by the villain Esmeralda
is fighting against racism and violence
at the hands of the church but the movie
is just so good
Esmeralda is one of the toughest
fiercest Disney characters ever she
stands up for justice knowing she could
literally lose her life for it
she also falls in love with a soldier
but she can't stand him at first
Esmeralda and Phoebus get into a sword
fight he tries to compliment her by
telling her to fight almost as well as a
man seriously Phoebus but does Morrell
de just tosses his insult right back at
him
she says funny I was going to say the
same thing about you go girl
Esmeralda has no time for men to think
she's anything less than amazing we love
her free spirit and the way she stands
up for herself and others give me your
hand
just let me see it hmm we're wrapping up
this list with Disney's queen of clap
backs there is no Disney character who
has mastered sarcasm quite like mogera
from Hercules she's not your typical
Disney love interest she is independent
and takes charge
she doesn't pretend to be innocent in
fact she made a deal with the god of the
underworld to save her ex she's as much
of a hero as Hercules himself we find
out exactly how sassy meg is the moment
we meet her she's trying to fight off a
creepy centaur
but she doesn't want another man coming
and saving her she says she can handle
this of course she eventually comes
around and realizes that Hercules is
different from other guys but that line
is the perfect clock back for
independent women everywhere we love
that she's not innocent she's flirty and
jaded but she really loves Hercules she
really set the tone for the future women
of Disney which disney clap back do you
think is the most savage let us know in
the comments section below thanks for
watching the things give this video a
big thumbs up see you next time